[Music]
last year i did quite a few games
from this book called the chess secrets
giant of not innovation
i did giants of strategy that is one of
my favorite books
ever there is like another one heroes of
classic gay
chess and there's a giants of innovation
so i intend to do
uh one of each at least
this week and next week this is just um
one of those
amazing books that anybody should be
able to do that
and today we are also working on the
chess-based software
software because well first of all i
think it's a
i've grown up using that so i'm very all
my files and everything is here
and um it's the most professional tool
in the chess world in my opinion and
besides that my chest wasn't allowing me
to upload these games there and this was
um
beginning to bug me a little so i was
just like let's
save my energy and time and just
continue it's here so
i see that the viewers are joining in
more all right great so the first game
is a game played by
one and only changes and uh versus
anderson and this was in 1866
which is so weird because
chess is surprisingly one of the things
that i do like about
um earlier centuries because the more i
i'm taking it
healthcare ethics just ethics and
history-wise
it gets quite but
anyways besides that this is a great
chess game we are going to enjoy that
part of
1860s and all right so
this was very interesting because um
i teach a lot of kids and a lot of pride
lessons and they
all have this um they all want to start
attacking pretty immediately but i have
to tell them don't
don't play moves such as f4 right away
and then there goes the stance and he
plays that
so kind of um interesting
don'ts uh anyways so this idea is with
well
f4 is obviously a
pretty great idea nothing wrong with
that but
um that's not we're not looking at this
game purely just for its openings
i've actually played uh i've actually
played
king's gambit few times with white but
i've had it
way more happen to me as black anywho
um taking is a very usual thing i still
do that because i want to play this
queenish fours and i want to enjoy
an easy win it rarely actually goes that
way
but d5 is another one that you
definitely should be aware of
it's more of a personal choice but i
usually take it and i i've
i've tried this g5 a lot in uh
faster chess games compared to classical
g5 is definitely doable but it makes it
a little
um questionable when we start thinking
about
the development aspect of it right now
nothing is attacking
f4 so even if you want to be creative
and hold your pawn
i would still recommend trying to
develop maybe you can try to come over
to
e7 and the g6 maybe you can try knight
c6 nothing wrong with that
ideally if you could do d5 that would be
perfect i know there are a lot of things
with like bishop d6 at some point it
would like
like it's a it's so so so many different
um lines uh musa we
are on chess-based and not a website the
software
and as the most professional software is
uh it's as professional as software's
get
um it's one of the first ones that i
started with and i'm like it's so easy
to store
um your files and databases and organize
everything
but that's not the point and i wish you
guys could see this but gmp she's
sitting
right here right behind the computer
literally and he's having fun because we
got to go
out for about an hour or two today under
some i'll be posting pictures on that
for those of you who are uh interested
but
all right so g5 i want to get a little
bit of um
opinions from you guys so what do you
think about this g5
should should white be happy would you
do this as black
what do you think how to dean white
should continue because this g5
is clearly saying well you're not going
to take my pawn but
at the same time it's also saying i
ain't going to be short castling anytime
soon
so what do you think what do you think
about this position
what should white do and basically
besides defending the pawn what is
black's other
ideas
any any opinion is welcome just
make sure to type
i remember last year well actually last
year around march
it wasn't as clear actually march was
still pretty good the first half
but um pretty pandemic-wise we would go
to the club there would be there would
be
some live audience well i mean physical
audience and then there would be
a bunch of you guys online and it was
kind of fun because
it took me a while to be comfortable to
teach online
and in person like at the same time and
so i wasn't reading the chat as
efficiently and
like ben simon would read the chat and
then
he would he would be behind the computer
he would like read out he'd read the
chat out loud and i thought that was so
cool
but we are not doing that right now
because
well i finally got uncomfortable with
teaching online
and the cat is incapable of reading
all right so gary you are correct we uh
yeah this does weaken the king side and
um it is a good idea to try and
use that from white so something like d4
definitely welcomed this bishop oh the
cat is moving the camera
you're gonna move all right
so another idea is with the bishop
bishop trying to go to c4 because c4
um looking at f7 already having
some ideas coming up so um
and that's what's changed bishop c4 easy
peasy
trying to simply go um
well develop nothing wrong with
developing oh exxon
best of luck to you speaking public
speaking is
um can be very fun if you're passionate
about the subject
yeah i think teaching online chess has
helped a lot with that aspect
because sometimes i get to be a little
dorky and a little goofy
as my friends say so it's good to know
that i can still have those
characteristics and um be able to do
this online too
yeah it's a it's really hard to be
always completely professional and
completely
know exactly what to say uh kudos to
people who can't do that
i think caleb is one of them but anyways
um
so for after bishop c4 well
this is this part like up until here i'm
pretty comfortable okay
well white tried to do again but black
accepted the gamut
black is trying to still hold on to the
pawn
and black is still pretty comfortable
with this position
this move g4 that's what i don't really
understand
this one i really really do not
understand it
because i mean it makes sense in the sen
in the way that well i mean if you move
this knight then you're there's going to
be a queenish for but
is it really worth it to push this
knight to go to e5 because
then where else would the knights go i'm
not gonna play knight d4 and block my
own pawn and i'm not gonna
do weird sacrifices when my position is
not ready but when i do knight if
sorry what i do knight e5 first of all
the g4 pawn
is pretty um under pressure
second of all your f7 is another clear
target
so instead of trying to go for g4 black
should have tried to go for bishop g7
it would have it would have been more
logical you already played g5 might as
well go for bishop g7
if there will be some d4 sure
but now i could try to maybe hope for a
little uh push over here
maybe i could try and get my knight up
and try to get
this guy out it's i still have a lot of
choices
it's not the end of the world but when i
play g4 it's extremely sharp and it's
extremely
unprepared so i don't like g4
alright so after g4 um
white continues with knight e5 logical
check
don't do g3 it's just weird make sure
you
do the normal moves even if you're if
even if your position is good but it's
not as perfect as you want it to be it
doesn't mean that you have to go
um off the rail and play something like
g3 make sure you always keep your king
as safe as humanly possible
but that doesn't necessarily mean
castling that's another great video that
we did
last year when should we castle
i believe that's a hot topic in the
upcoming book that i'm writing with my
brother
so keep your eyes out for that too
um okay so in the game
it's black to move black played knight
h6
what do we think about this is knight h6
good
is something with let's go back
is knight f6 a better idea
is f3 so i'm gonna give you a few
options and then i'm gonna wait
for some feedback which one do you think
is better
uh essa i do not intend to do my own toy
channel
at least for foreseeable future
especially because the only thing that i
do besides
um well the the the chess that i do here
is study for foreseeable future
so it's not really my cup of tea to sit
in front of um twitch and just
study sounds like a very um
chill thing to do just silence studying
and letting other viewers join to study
and
it sounds like a horrible idea but it
might pay off
you never know what people like so what
do you think what do you think black
wants to do
hello hassa
ah i really wish you guys could see what
i see there's a cute there's the cutest
cat
sitting right behind the chessboard in
my laptop and it
is just a view
any suggestion knight f6 knight h6
f3 which one would you want to choose
all right i see knight f6 is a
solid uh idea anybody anybody likes
moving pawn to f3
okay okay i see few f3 votes i see a few
um mainly knives f6 so far
okay so the thing is knight f6 makes
sense
but it's kind of uh interesting because
this is black's oldest defense
like this move my dev6 has been played
from like 1600s which is so weird when i
think about it
and this game was in 1866 so
when if you can if you can call this
move knight f6
older than 1866 then
we definitely have a interesting thing
on our mind
knight f6 is definitely possible and
if something like queenie won then you
can definitely take that
but your f7 is a problem
and i am not entirely happy with this
something maybe d5 maybe h5 maybe
anyways just move this bishop somewhere
next g4 is going to fall
if bishop h5 makes sense because then
you want to take over here
without any defense so
i'm gonna go back and remove this f6
around uh what about tonight maybe c6
does that look interesting you would be
living uh you would be giving your f7
but
knight c6 is interesting because if um
take then bishop c5 and black gains a
little bit more activity
and even you wouldn't really go for
queen exchange you would do your best to
try to make the game as crazy as humanly
possible
which is a good thing in this situation
because well exxon there is no
there's there's not a problem with
knight f knight h6
i'm just providing other options i think
this
this knight c6 would be the best
um try and if you try to take
then boom bishop c5 i'm going for easy
pc checkmate on f2
try to cover it boom g3 each one you eat
the
the rook now again attacking your clean
and then developing and next knights
coming to g4
well if you if you didn't allow me
then i can actually form a pretty solid
attack
and yeah there is this rook missing but
it's a very scary position
i wouldn't exactly want to be white in
this position
anyways uh this is just another option
to have and this
was for example played about a hundred
years this
exact position was played a hundred
years
after this game of stance anderson
sorry andres anderson
i i'm gonna have an issue pronouncing
that
uh this the position that i'm showing
you right now this game this exact
moves were played in a game of
um goncharenko
and alexia in 1963 so
almost a hundred years after the steins
scheme
anyways this is such a weird position
i'm just
giving myself a little headache about us
but as you can see
checkmate is very close and black
actually won after this move
which is not really surprising after
take they could be czech here
queen e3 so pretty much checkmated two
or you lose your queen
which is again naturally ideal anywho
this was just to show you a little bit
of crazy things that happens when you
have peace activity
uh that's why now we want to look at f3
just a little bit
what do we think does this f3 look
interesting again
knight c6 is the most interesting way to
continue
but what about f3 does this gain some
cool stuff for us and if you're just
tuning in
we are looking at uh the
one game that was played between states
and
in 1866 and
if you just witnessed that crazy active
line
that was a game within a game
ha that that game was happened um
in 1963 so a hundred years after the
shayna's game
so we are just promoting for peace
activity now what do we think about this
f3
what do you think white should do i kind
of like this just going for d4 because
i am not about to take this and i'm not
entirely sure if i want to spend the
time to just move my bishop
or even my knight because we just saw
what happened in the last one
so let's just go for after f3
just push push pawn no bishop c5s no
funny business there um
and so after d4
white what do you think white should do
oh i'm so i'm sorry after white plays d4
what do you think black should do black
has
few options to still try and keep an
active game
you can develop this knight you can try
to take over here
give check any preference
that is true after bishop c5 d4 still
did exist
um yeah the exactly asan that's why
knight c6 was the better choice instead
of f3 to block
d4 as well good thinking
uh however if right now for example take
take queen h3 and then you can also just
bring out your knights stop all this
funny fun stuff on f7
and um this is this is this is the
doable game
nothing entirely wrong with it but um
if you were going to play knight h6 you
might you might as well
start it with knight h6 hello exquisite
i'm glad you're joining us we are
looking at a
fun game that stands played uh back
in 1866
so you can never know
um there were very few uh amazing chess
players
around that time one of them was
obviously stanis
he is the first known and accepted world
champion
so we're looking at a game that he
played
and he is playing it as white so
after d4 um knight of six is also
possible but i'm not gonna get too deep
in that because
this is again the same ideas we're
trying to
white has such a better center but black
has a little bit of peace activity going
on on my king
so yep yes exactly that's why there's a
queen on h3
instead of having developed other pieces
exactly what
yep see like there's so many different
ways that this position could continue
but the bottom line is that black
doesn't have enough pieces to form an
attack just yet
so in the game
anderson played knight h6
trying to bring some of those pieces to
the game
d4 now again f3 was
possible but again knight c3 and it
could have
i mean the thing is like when you play
f3 you expect
take whoops you spec take but take
doesn't necessarily have to happen
and that's why this doesn't exactly work
so after d4
f3 is still too early what else can we
do how else can we try to develop
even just a little bit
any suggestions
to be fair there is not there's i mean
there are a lot of things that
white can do but um
sorry black can do to face this
the pretty awesome center and peace
activity
by white but it doesn't necessarily mean
that they're actually good ideas
so f3 was a suggestion that should
always be considered
d5 spicy uh d5 is too
too aggressive you don't really have a
better you don't really have a good
follow-up after that d6 makes sense you
want to kick this light
and now when the knight moves has to go
to d3
now you can potentially do f3
[Music]
very interesting comments and the chat
is looking at this position it
seems uh it's either between two gm's or
two nine hundreds
well stainless is no 900
neither is anderson yep this is the same
anderson that i remember which i'm
pretty sure it is
that one was also german this one is
also german so
um to be completely fair this is this is
a great idea to continue
if you were to play f3 before you played
d6
it's it's possible but it only gives a
little bit of this knight c3
chance and now if i play
this is like i mean there's again
nothing wrong with this
and these um this idea with
f3 so in this specific position
stanis has three games that he has
played as white
so again and he has won every single
one of them so the conclusion is
don't let strangers play e4 e5 f4 would
you
but besides that it doesn't really
matter if you play f3 now or not
uh d6 is something that i would do it's
more solid
it it forces you to put the knight back
and now i get the chance to decide do i
want to play f3
do i want to play potentially bishop g7
can i do knight c6 it gives me more
options i don't have to immediately
commit to f3
and the other thing is after f3 white is
never going to take on f3
so white might simply do this knight c3
and now if i
decide to let's say take it's possible
but i can't get my pieces to work i
can't bring that my bishops i can't
bring out my knights they're all blocked
so
it does not make any sense to just take
f3 and just
start going with it and farsi i think we
have this expression
um let me try to remember it
that way but that's me doing yeah and
like it means like you hold a slipper
and you run
which is supposed to be um meaning that
you like
yours the slipper is your weapon and
you're running with just like a
slipper weapon which is makes more sense
in farsi
so um here's a little pun too
haha and anyways
so now the thing is knight c3 again
is possible it's a good transposition
but
so is bishop f4 for white
and we try to well
the main thing we should do as white is
make sure that we're developing and make
sure that we
are well not making weird mistakes or
just taking
that's a good start so
what do you think white should do as
white you know you have the better
center you know you have these two
interesting pieces you have a lot of
options to go
around with your pieces but
your king is a little bit questionable
so how can you try to
make that a little bit less questionable
to put it
oh well i grew up in iran and i have to
go to school in iran so i learned a lot
of
like different more day-to-day languages
i guess
if you were if you weren't born in iran
you might have not really known these
slangs i guess yeah g3
very interesting and the thing with g3
is that
so one thing that i don't think i was
very clear on
was that this game
[Music]
um this specific game is the tenth game
of their match between us and anderson
and the quite fun part of it is
that this exact same position had
happened
again in the second round of the match
and in the second round the anderson had
made the mistake and he played queen to
h3
which obviously we're not gonna go king
g1 obviously we're not gonna go king f2
because i don't want you to give me
checks so king yuan
and um quite funny because if queen goes
to g2
knight f2 and your queen is a little bit
trapped my friend
next book we should have fun and it's
like already back pipe time for the
queen
um if you were smart and you just tried
to run away with the queen because
again remember knight f4 coming up your
queen is going to be trapped so if you
and if you try to run
i can just develop and this is the
second game of their match
in which stanis did win the game
um after i want to say about 20 more
moves or so stainless continued which is
developing got the bishop out
got this night a little better got the
queen out and
it was a it was a very interesting game
but
um besides that
so let me go back back back so let's say
now stains has learned from
his um sorry
anderson has learned from his mistake on
this in a second the game is not going
to play queen street anymore
so let's say uh goes going to e7
now how should we continue as white
you can easily see the the advantage
coming up right
this super cool center the pieces being
all
sharp and ready to poke around hello i'm
annie
so where else how else what else am i
supposed to get out
yes my c3 the easiest way to continue
oh hi david i have played against daisy
it's been a
long time i believe we played together
in the first round of world junior
championship 2013.
i was a baby i was 15 years old
i missed being 15. and i had
i actually managed to get a little bit
of a better position out of the opening
and then i messed it up and the
transition to middle game middle game to
end game
anyways i'm glad that everybody are
looking at this
knight c3 good job knight c3 let's say
black is also sharp and still wants to
go ahead with trying and exchanging some
of this material
now what should whites do i'm maddie and
that's also a very great question
why would pg be checking these grumpild
lines
and for uh
for this position i think the
main things to consider is how am i
going to
um save or exchange this bishop because
if we decide ah
i got one wrong answer d5
doable but not really great because now
if let's say this knight gets to e5 then
the black
black is kind of actually holding this
so you have to be very careful and if
you play d5
you are extremely committed to playing
this e5
right after two but you have to be very
careful because
this doesn't exactly work if this
sacrifice is not
ready you can't just go around and do
weird stuff
you don't have if your rick was on e1
yeah i would i would get behind that too
but it's not so you have to be very
careful this does not work
it looks like it does but it doesn't
white cannot
play like this you need more pieces
so um
now it's quite interesting
because in this game shane is played
bishop b3
and it really puzzles me because
um staying it's in i believe
in the um game eight well actually not
me um the
the um analysis on
done by chess secrets um
in game eight uh states kind of messed
it up a little and
he played this d5 and he ended up losing
but what it's not what puzzles me and
what puzzles me is that
they would just play the same opening
over and over again so when
ustedes was white there would be king's
gambit
game two four i i'm not sure about what
happened in game six game eight and game
ten
exchanges is white and it's this game
it's the same exact
first few moves which is really
just why i mean
today when we follow the world the uh
world championship matches
it's so much more diverse
black has i mean berlin aside
um there's so many different ways to
play it there's neither of
those petrov um i don't believe there
was a
french in the last one so
but it's not just every single line
every single game oh
so that my frustration aside
yes you did yep all right so bishop
beatrice is a good idea
and the one thing that i would really
like to know more about
is um when these players
like how did they modify it because
standards was the strongest chess player
of his time
so that's the one thing like
i know that's a lot of the different uh
teams different countries different
nationalities
have different ways of approaching uh
how to prepare for a tournament
especially when um and in soviet union
there was
the whole concept of teamwork because
if i'm not mistaken the government was
very big on the chess and
chess was one of the
something that was considered so noble
which again
comes up in the queen's gambit too
the tv show so it's quite interesting
because
the stanis didn't really have
that huge team rarely anybody had that
type of teamwork so if you had a
question about a move
you had to sit there and you had to
think yourself there wasn't this
databases there wasn't no way there was
no internet there were no computers
there were no engines to
go and figure it out on your own so the
way that the players would find answers
to
the questions they had about a specific
move like chess
it really does amaze me so
yeah if i was ever gonna get deep in the
history of chess
that is one of the extremely
important things i would want to know on
how how do they just
like because when you think on your own
you
you get to a block so that's why i like
bouncing the ideas off of other people
but if you don't have that team but yeah
that's just one of the
historical aspects of chess that i
really wanted to
just it it never stops to amaze me
any fool let's get back to this
cool match between stevens and anderson
let's say bishop g7
bishop v3 finally take um
if you were to make a mistake in castle
this is quite funny because just queen
d2 and your knight is a little in a
pickle
and um it's the only way to
to defend the knights is to play like
queen f6 but then i'll attack that
and um i think we're just gonna knight
that four so maybe
bishop e7 if you move the stroke boom
knight f4
and your queen is trapped so it's very
interesting yeah
so let's go back to if not castle and
if bishop takes on b3
now we take back c6 now well we just
looked at some
cool ideas that white could do trying to
develop how do you think why it should
continue
now and yes exquisite i have read about
it and yeah that's why
fisher was so his life was so amazing
because
he was alone going against um
he had him he had some support from the
government and he had a lot of fans but
he was alone he didn't have anybody to
do the teamwork with
at least chess was so it's so
it's so weird i mean
it doesn't like the more i think about
it the more like
he really did a humongous job with going
against
um mixing chess and politics and
all the things that he had to face and
well we got queen's gambit out of that
so
yep i'm i i i
own it up i suck with pronunciations i'm
not going to be able to fix that anytime
soon
i'd be sure to work
on it but don't expect lunch the best i
can give you is stainless
i have problems pronunciating anderson
at right distance right now
which is weird i shouldn't have problem
with that
anyways all right ah thanks well not
necessarily queen c1 though queen d2
trying to go for this but a little more
active knight's gotta go to g8 if this
knife wants to stay alive and
now are we finally at a position to
start
breaking these bad boys out ideally i
would want to have the rook on e1
before i do that but
the famous philosopher jagger once said
you can't always get what you want so
i like that song
king f2 is possible but it still feels a
little
um my problem is if
i if i move the stroke and if there's no
more
defense on this part then h then this h
pawn can become a little monstrous so
uh stefan that is true i wasn't
mentioning as an anderson being
a soviet union player he was playing for
germany
but my point was just how it's
it's doesn't make any sense i can't i
can't understand
how they would all alone come up with
answers to the questions um right now
it's so weird because
uh when i'm preparing for an exam i have
way too many resources that i don't know
which one to go for
the problem isn't the lack of material
is the extent of it and i
it's like i study from this and then i
go recap from that
and then i do questions from this and
then i go find the answer to question in
there
so it's like five different contents
review five different it's like
taking exams and oh but
yes i hope i made this confusion going
on
um exquisite i wouldn't really do king
of two just yet because i want to be
sure that you're not gonna push this
h-pawn
so what about something in the center
can i push anything in there
e5 thank you yes and the fun thing about
e5 is that now that we force this knight
away
um you can this this knight can't really
go
anywhere can't really get involved in
the game and that's what i want i don't
want your knight to get involved so
um you have to be very careful as black
and if you
you can't really take on e5 um
it's taking on e5 opens a whole
different kind of worms
you could easily take back now bishop c5
coming out now knight trying to go
around coming up and now
rook d1 is another thing so
you shouldn't take that black correctly
played this d5
trying to still keep some of this um
curtains draped and
drapes on the kings i guess that was a
better one
um now white still wants to get pieces
out so let's go oh wrong thing bishop g5
let's say queen e6
and now what i really want to start
using my pieces i want to use my knights
i want to get my rug rolling
i want my queen to be in a better spot
where
how why
definitely king's gambit this is you you
would not get this position from
anything else if not king's damage
knight f4 the problem with knight f4
is that the queen gets to go to f5 and
is attacking my bishop i don't want that
nice c5 interesting but
let me let me um poke your brain a
little
your knight on d3 is
pretty um pretty good you might want to
go to f4 you might want to go to b4
you you um you
your nikon d3 is very active
maybe anything else ricardo i am so glad
that you
are um worried about peaches well-being
pc is right here napping right behind
the laptop which is
so weird i
moved my setup around so we could
capture his majesty on his
tree but now he goes and he hides behind
the laptop
so what to do cats right um
let me let me try to throw in more hints
how about this knight could this knight
be a little bit more
activated my rook is doing a little bit
of something here it's holding your rope
captive
so any any other ideas i like my t7 just
not not not the right knight yeah let's
go for
this one knight a4 i want to do knight
b6 eat your rook
to start with and i also want to do
knight c5 given the choice
now if knight tries to go to a6 all
right i could undo knight b6 no big e
now we'll get now i got rid of the c3
knights that
i couldn't really do anything but i
couldn't have played knight four no
knight b
fives no nice e2's that mic was just a
little extra
so in the game black played
queen g6 now what
can i eat this pond pretty please
i really do want to eat that pot
to be fair if black tried to believe
funny and play queen c8
to stop this eating it wouldn't really
work because i would still have
pawn to e6 now if you try to take it
ah perfect i'll be taking that and you
can't really take it because i have this
cool rookie one
stuff and if you try to run i'll just
gets district involved
uh anyways let's go back to
not queen c8 let's go queen g6
yep i do like the idea of rookie one but
i want to eat this
now i have knight d6 coming up let's say
you're trying to get pieces out boom
and this this move i think was
my uh moment in the game
because this is such a such a weird move
like i i thought about simply trying to
develop i thought maybe just king f2
rookie one i thought about maybe rook a6
queen a5
i thought about different ways to go
about it but
i never thought about this move and
that's why it's such a great move
so why to move what to do i'm going to
give you guys a minute
because there's still a few moves left
on the board
about 10 or so and i really do want to
get to it
so what do you think
is the best move for white
nope not queen before nope not easy
um bishop going to is this wait
oh i guess you mean instead of might
point to h6
it's doable but
um even if you got rid of my white even
if you got rid of that
white bishop on g5 it wouldn't really
help you as much
nope i don't really see anybody saying
this no i
threw k61 from one of my initial ideas
too
nope uh-uh ain't gonna work all right
i'm gonna go ahead and spill the beans
h3 i'm just like oh my god
i did not see this move i did not even
bother thinking about this one when i
was looking at it
i thought if i want to get my rook
activated i should go for king f2 but
that was not the case this
is so weird because um
there are like white hats trying to like
do a little like
explosion so in order to do that you
need to
gather a little more material to build
up your explosion
which is a weird analogy but it's kind
of what's going on right now because
now white wants to try and
open up the center a little bit but you
have to be very careful
exactly h3 is so logical but i i didn't
think about it
yeah uh let's say black makes a mistake
to try and stop queen b4s we just get
boom boom
and now we get 24 attacking on g4
uh attacking on f7 if you try to be
funny with h5
boom and then queen f5
and you lose your queen
so that's one way to go about it
another way is let's say why black
doesn't make this mistake and black
plays f6
now take now if keep in mind if you take
it i can take on h6 and
if you take over here just clean check
and this is quite miserable for black
so black didn't do this black played
bishop to f8
instead of taking bishop goes to f8
now this was another holy
cow moment um
and here white plays knight b7
these might be a little out of scope but
they are such
great ideas because you play knight b7
you don't
just want to play knight c5
you also want to start creating
more threats on the queen side so let's
say knight f5 boom mission f4
defending my g3 simple move and also
beginning to
get more access to your queen side let's
say
take sample moves just king f2
i'm just going to defend my g3 no biggie
attack and this was another pretty cool
move
don't rush eating because that's what uh
that would not really end up well for
you a lot of checks coming up a lot of
takes coming up
don't do that black could actually end
up winning this
your king is super weak and i have a cat
shaking my camera key you gotta move
here big huge all right
um so let's say no bishop aj
so say we are smart let me take this
pawn back i'm defending my g3 now i want
to eat your
rook now uh in the game white
uh black played bishop h6 however if
rook g8 was played
this was another this move i actually
did find which was pretty interesting
just not wrong piece just queen a5 i
want to go queen c7
i simply want to poke around your king
and enjoy that
uh and so in the game black was
smart played bishop h6 now whites to
move what do you think we should do
we are approaching our final positions
so what you think we gotta do
i agree bishop six is a little bit too
late
any what's the first things we should
think about
before we start thinking about queen b4
i and such
i think rook h6 is definitely reasonable
but
we could do it a little bit better
a little bit faster
yeah knight c5 good job knight c5
when the king moves now boom even if you
went to e7 i would still boom you
and let's say you take back now what do
you think wishing we can do
basically think about what's the fastest
way of winning
anything to eat any cool checks
uh rook rookie one is definitely
interesting but i just want to eat my
free stuff
it's a full piece why not
if you try to trap it ah i'll just run
away that's a full piece
uh in the game black tried to continue
play it's queen h5
now again check and this
was amazing i'm gonna let you guys
figure this one out so now it is
weinstein move
what do you think we should do
not necessarily mate in one but
rockets one exactly good job everybody
if you eat it now i will give you
checkmate coming up very very soon
like two more moves and there we go
and if you don't take it let's go back
back back
let's say knights g4 eh just king g1
you can't even eat it now f2 uh king g2
and well you still have that extra night
so we're gonna use that extra night
and we are finally going to
win another full piece too and this is
actually where
uh anderson resigned so this was a
very very amazing example of peace
activity
another question of how how should we
keep our king safe because
clearly i didn't need to castle and
clearly my opponent
supposedly got the king in the right
square
and how much material matters there are
all of these concepts that we
keep hearing about all the time but
we never exactly fully understand so
this is a perfect example of it and what
i really like about it
is that it was a full match and they
kept
playing this opening every time
stainless was white they played in game
2
4 8 10 at least
so um very interesting game
and with that i am going to
end this stream but be sure to join us
on twitch for in about
i'm gonna give it about seven minutes so
now it's seven central time
make sure to join us in about seven
minutes on twitch
so we can do a game review for two hours
straight hopefully gmp will stop hiding
behind the laptop and will join us
so i am going to leave our uh steel
chest on
twitch here so make sure to join us
and uh we are going to run the stream
there
stand our game send your games to me on
leachat you are more than welcome to
stamp those
links yes i'm manny we made some
adjustments
um and we are hoping to
make a little bit more time for viewers
to send games so yes
exactly basically club game review i'll
see you soon
make sure to join me on twitch for
remainder of the next two hours
i'll see you in about seven minutes